turning overseas to Ukraine's
counter-offensive against Russia which
is most definitely underway this morning
including new fighting near the eastern
city of bakmud which Russia took in May
after months of fighting Deborah patta
is inside Ukraine for us
Ukraine is finally on the March spring
has become summer and defensive
operations switched to offensive ones
just this morning as the battle
continued nearby Ukrainian troops
claimed they'd liberated storage of air
in the dunetsk region
at first we were met with heavy Russian
Artillery said this Soldier but then we
took it back house by house celebrations
are muted though there is no time to
pause they must continue pressing
forward over the weekend in the village
of laudatne Fighters were seen trading
gingerly through the ruins of another
shattered building before hoisting the
Ukrainian flag through the smashed
window of what used to be a local
community center
we're kicking the enemy out said this
Soldier it is the warmest feeling there
is and close by in this question these
troops proclaimed yet another victory
for Ukraine here tears of joy of a
different kind Ukrainian soldiers
captured by Russian forces in Bahamut
Maria Poland elsewhere have returned
home more than 90 Fighters swapped in a
prisoner exchange with the Kremlin all
of this will be welcome news for
ukrainians still reeling from the horror
of last week's kahovka Dam catastrophe
and the ongoing Terror of rescuing
stranded flood victims and a Russian
fire
now Russia claims it has repelled a
number of other advances along the front
line but cave is reluctant to talk about
its counter-offensive and despite these
recent modest gains the big push Tony is
still to come
once again in Ukraine Deborah thank you
very much